You'll sometimes run into textures being flipped top to bottom, with the y axis
reversed. In 3js, you can correct this by setting the flip y parameter on your
texture. The texture coordinates are a bit trickier when the texture's flipped.
Say our image is 512 by 512 pixels in size, with the upper left hand corner of
this texture being 0, 0. This is different than how U,V gets defined which use
the lower left hand corner as 0, 0. Also recall that each of the U,V
coordinates point at the outer edge of the image, not the texel center. The
question to you is what Texel corresponds to U,V coordinates 0.2, 0.7? What I
want here are two integers, not floating point numbers. Each Texel has a
location in an array. I want this location.